disrespectful people do dumb why do
you think people automatically think
that the woman's the victim when she
gets hit when often times she hit first
women are looked at as fragile little
beings and oh you can't hit a woman it's
that woman out there saying she wants to
meet girls and they playing it to their
victim it's not even it's not even
necessarily that you put your hand on a
guy women don't understand the power of
our influence and our voice right it's
how you talk to a man right if you can
stir up some things in him and entice
them in a way that make him want to put
his hand on you and people will say oh
it wasn't justifiable because she didn't
hit you even though that's not
appropriate either but it's like women
why are you running your mouth like this
to a man